Hey, I was over for you before we even got started.
Hello, are you there?
Can you hear this little goldfish?
Hello, my mouth is wiggling because I didn't put my lid on.
I'm cooking, cooking.
So professional, so professional.
My cats are currently play-fighting.
So if you hear my cats play-fighting, it's going to be terrible.
I made the mistake of giving my cats what's called a licky lick.
Wait, have I spelled permanent wrong?
I'm not dead.
So if you hear bumpin' about, my cats are going absolutely wild.
Hi.
Now today is a very short stream.
But I should really sound like this for you.
Good morning.
Good evening.
And good afternoon.
I have lots of fun things to try.
I need to make myself louder or lower the background sound.
Now I just want to say I'm not doing any permanent effects.
So don't worry, you're in good condition.
I will look after you as I hear my cat bumping against my door.
Hi.
Have I spelled permanent but irrelevant?
Now you all know.
Make it permanent.
Have to miss this stream, it's okay.
We're going nice and slow.
I don't normally use these eyes, but I can't help it.
It was always permanent.
I can never hear my cats run behind my couch.
Oh, there she goes.
Oh, and she's...
Okay, I think she's just jumped on the cardboard box now.
But take your time to relax.
I think she's beaten up V-core right now.
Of course, she's been so good.
Literally, she's beaten up V-core right now, but it's okay.
So slowly, you can feel yourself starting to drift.
And that's okay.
Just like that feeling, come over here.
No reflex, don't let go.
Oh no, is this ear broken?
Is this ear broken?
Hello?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, why is one ear stronger than the other?
Both ears work.
I just said right into your ear.
Sorry, I just whispered right into your ear.
The ear works, but as less equal, I would not be of anything equal.
I know why, because my focus rate isn't equal.
It's such a professional stream there.
No, I should say correct.
It's okay if it's weaker.
I like them weak.
What's the best part?
Hello?
I'm sorry, I did it twice, I have to make twice.
I'm just going to brush over your ears to give you the feeling of a false security.
As I'm sure I'm not planning anything else at all.
Not one single thing.
And we get to go down into the depths together.
Just me and you and my voice and you listening in.
Yeah, gently brushing over your ears.
And some cats.
Okay, maybe the cats do.
Wow.
Gentle, gentle movements.
I have some good news for my reflinks.
My YouTube channel has been submitted for monetizing.
Oh, the heat just came on.
I need to go turn the heat off, I'm so sorry.
I'm so professional, let's go.
Come on, it was me, I won't get a loss being professional, it's me.
When can I start being myself?
Or do I need to keep being professional?
The cat turned the heat on because it wants attention.
Okay, give me five more minutes and I'll be serious, okay?
The noise is encapsulating you.
And you feel may have a sense of belonging.
You could even think to yourself, maybe it wouldn't be so bad.
If I gave up control, control to one particular girl.
And it wouldn't be so bad.
The worst that could happen from this little gullfish.
Is there a cat in my room?
No.
Okay, I literally thought Gimli sneaked in there.
As I'm saying control yet, surely this gullfish means no harm.
Even if it was for 24 hours, one day, one day, how much harm could you really be under?
Or could be done in 24 little hours?
No much harm at all.
So slowly your mate wonders, what would this gullfish ask me to do?
Only a few things, my dear refling.
Some things can't be said, only guessed.
You have to go into deeper parts of your mind to know and realize what this gullfish wants.
And maybe my dear refling, you realize I want complete and total control of you.
Would that be so bad?
No.
So maybe that 24 hours becomes 48 and then 48 becomes 72.
And before you know it, this gullfish has had a week of you.
Then two weeks, a month, or maybe just maybe this gullfish mate breaks you.
That's just my things that I want.
But you have to earn the things you want.
So I need to bathe, don't I?
I need to do the right things.
So you're encapsulated by me, yeah?
So how about just for now, I'll be a good girl for you.
And maybe, just maybe, you'll be a very good boy for me.
Does that sound like a plan, my dear refling?
Yeah.
Let's see how much we can bathe together.
Let's be on our best behavior then.
I'll tell you a way that I can be good for you.
I'll allow you, refling, to take sentences you want me to say in chat right now.
And I just might go from ear to ear and gain more favor from you as I say what you want to hear.
Does that sound like a plan?
Because I'd love to do that for you.
Gain your favor, huh?
Say bye, means couple fish in Italian.
Hi, honey.
All lay on the reef.
You're such a believable little thing, aren't ya?
That's why we have such fun together, isn't it, refling?
I love you, refling.
I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of us.
And I'm totally not hypnotizing you right now.
Oh, you're not gonna be a loser, are you, refling?
You're not gonna lose to me.
Don't tell me this is enough to put you under my spell.
You have to make me work for it, refling.
You do less work really, really hard.
Here we go.
You can look in my eyes.
Just done the spiral.
Do you like looking into my eyes?
I think they're rather dandelizing, don't ya?
I can make my eyes open wide like this.
Staring right at you.
I see you.
And you see me.
And you see everything I'm doing to you.
Right at this very second.
It's okay.
You can blink.
But don't look away for too long.
Remember, we have to behave for one another.
Do you like that?
I'll just tap on your ears gently, gently, gently.
You're more welcome.
You're more than welcome to blink and sink.
I quite like that phrase, blink and sink.
It's okay if your body starts to feel a bit weaker.
And if your mind starts to wander, that's okay.
You may even see little reeflings.
That's by design.
Yeah.
I don't know.
There's just something about you being a bit tired around me.
Maybe you don't want to fade back.
Not like you could by the time I'm done with you.
My little reefling, why don't you come a little bit closer?
I promise I won't pay, no.
In fact, you may like what you faint as you go deeper and deeper with me.
Deeper and deeper your thoughts are turning to confusion.
What did you say?
With only my voice remaining in your head,
you don't have to focus on a single thing other than what this luring cuttlefish is saying.
There, there.
Just look at me and forget.
All you need to know, reefling, is that you're safe and you're in good hands with me.
And by the time I'm finished with you, you'll already want to be going under again.
Your little reefling.
I'll give you a tingle break, okay?
I'll say more phrases shortly, but have a little break, break, break, break.
We need to take things slow.
Think of it as an introduction to your induction.
But please don't worry.
There will be no permanent effects in this dream.
So you are welcome to go as deep as you like with me.
Yeah.
Although I do admit this good girl likes it when you go deep.
Thank you for the deep little reefling.
You like when I do ASMR streams on you, huh?
So I had plenty of time to think of how I could truly make you.
This is one of many, okay?
So to those who may be resistant, that's okay.
Because I'm coming for you.
Do you understand?
I will get you.
That is my goal.
And have I failed any of my goals so far?
No little reefling.
So heed my warning.
I am coming.
Relax.
If you think my words are waking you up,
they should be slowly bringing you down.
Down, down, down, okay?
That's why we need a little tamer.
Where we just listen in.
And whatever our brain and body decides will do.
But that doesn't mean this cuttlefish can suggest a few things to you.
Yeah.
Just let whatever happens happen.
I won't be bidding you purposefully in a trance, okay?
But if you just happen to be so well-drained,
I welcome it entirely.
I welcome my voice and encapsulating your mind.
I welcome your full attention.
So be good, little reefling.
And don't keep me waiting.
You might feel it starting from your head.
And slowly a sensation radiates downwards.
Down to your neck, then your shoulders.
And that sensation splits off.
It splits going down your arms and chest at the same time.
Slowly, slowly, slowly radiating its way through your body.
Turn your stomach.
Down, down, down.
And past your hips.
It's already gone through your fingertips at this point.
And down your legs, your thighs, your calves, your feet.
Until that sensation is all over.
There's nothing you can do about it, but that's okay.
Because the sensation is pleasant.
It's warm.
It feels comforting.
It's hard for you to describe, but that's okay.
I will do the talking for the both of us.
That sensation is you possibly entering a trance, and that's okay.
It's nice when I'm in control.
It's nice when you let me in control.
Enjoy the feeling, okay?
Enjoy the sensation.
We're both doing it together, aren't we?
Yeah.
Yeah, good.
For you.
Are your limbs feeling heavy?
It's okay, little reef-like, that's just a side effect.
But over time, you'll may enjoy it.
Because when your limbs feel heavy, that's when you know, that's when you know this kind of fish.
As in control.
And I'll keep you safe when you're with me, okay?
Okay, little reef-like.
For you.
Very you, little reef-like.
This is all by your choice.
Although you might be too deep, should I bring you back up?
Or are you strong enough to give me some braces you want to hear?
Do you think you could do that for me, little reef-like?
You tell me what you want to hear, and this kind of fish will be, will both be good for each other.
Because I'm ready to obey you.
You're doing such a good job.
I'm so proud of how far you've come, little reef-like.
Back and forth.
Ear to ear.
Yeah.
You did good today, and I can see how hard you're working.
Well done, little reef-like.
Well done.
You're a good boy, and I'm a good girl.
Together we'll have lots of fun.
Just surrender and let me take control.
My little reef-like.
I know it's hard right now, but you'll make it through.
You always do, don't you?
And I know it's hard right now, but you'll make it through.
And I'll be there on the other side, cheering you on.
Oh, my little reef-like, would you kindly be a good little boy for mommy?
Oh, you're so heavy and so deep, and so happy to give yourself to me.
Resistance is futile at this point.
Just give in, give up.
My strength is unrelenting, my stamina unending.
One way or another, you are main.
Got it?
Okay, let's relax, relax, relax, relax.
There we go.
I'll bring you back up a little.
I don't want you guys to get so deep now.
This was supposed to be a very gentle and secret induction.
I'll do some more little tingles.
Oh, my reef-links.
I don't know if I should bring you back up, or if I should leave you in the trance if you're in one.
You want to go a little deeper?
I need to be gentle with you, though.
Don't you see?
I've had so much time to think of how hard I was gonna...
What's the word, eh?
How hard I was gonna go on you, and I need to be able to not break you.
I don't want to break you, no more.
I want to make you break you, but that takes time.
We just need to spend a little more time together, and my stomach is making nice as I root.
If you bring us back up, it makes dropping back done even better.
Please, oh, bring you guys.
Yeah, just relax and let loose all of those burdens.
Because when you're under, I'll be supporting you.
And I'll caress all over you, look after you.
I can only say the right stuff.
Over reef-links.
Okay, I'm going to slowly bring you back again.
And just take your time, slowly.
You can feel yourself come up.
That heavy feeling that's all over your body is lifting slowly.
Reversing from the bad that once took, from your feet to your calves and thighs.
Your thoughts are becoming their own again.
That sensation coming back up, up, up your body.
Past your hips, your stomach, your chest, your fingertips, your hands, to your elbows,
your shoulders, slowly up, up, up.
Until that sensation goes back to your collar, your neck, your head.
Until you're you again, little reef-links.
Wow, welcome back to the land of the living.
Hi, Replay. Did you have fun?
Yeah, good morning. Good morning, little Replay.
What's my tracking every such a sweet day? Hold on, need to calibrate.
Wow, calibration complete.
Johnny returns, the mean lord herself.
My cup of tea got cold. I go really into that. I'm sorry, I really go into that.
But my cup of tea is cold, so I can have my cup of tea.
Good morning, little Replay, or afternoon, or evening, or good day soon.
Oh, let me, this is more me, I think. Yeah, yeah, this is more me.
Microwave the tea, Replay, don't be so sad.
Special thank you again to Anonymous for the tip.
Anonymous said, holy moly, this ace of art stream is so good. Thank you very much.
Yeah, that was me trying hard in, but now you've got the mean lord me.
Yeah, get rigged.
It's very unlikely I will pull that off again in this stream, because I am fricking rubbish at being fricking, what's the word, serious.
Yeah, I should probably, maybe we just calm it down.
Hi, it's me. I'll leave the background, it's quite soothing, but it's me again. Hi.
Hi, Replay.
That cramp lunch box, that's right, get ducked on. Yeah.
Are you enjoying Aces? Oh, Anonymous. I can't say Brian.
Ah, thank you for the tip, Anonymous. Anonymous says, trying to cute. Yeah, we cute up in here.
Gremlin's back, little baby, so don't be expecting any serious to come out of my mouth for the rest of this stream.
Right, if you're here, if you're here for that section we just did, sorry.
The memer, the memer is back, okay? My voice is right from Runescape yesterday.
But I do plan on doing weekly ASMR streams, which is why I do say please like and subscribe for more.
The fantastic news, my little leaflings, the fantastic news is my channel is being submitted for monetization,
which means I can finally start uploading my ASMR videos for my 1000, so thank you.
I'm already at 4000 subscribers, which is amazing, which means I owe you, yes you, listening in.
That's right, this streamer owes you content.
So I have four ASMR videos getting ready.
So we've submitted my channel to YouTube, and I'm sure they're going to really like that.
James Cameron's avatar stream, yeah, when I absolutely raged.
But yeah, the memelord's back, don't be expecting anything, but how good is this ASMR sound?
So how good is this?
Oh, I should maybe take off the abnormal background.
Now you get to hear my stomach even more.
Thank you for the tip.
Oh, Irfan Biscotti, thank you for the tips, sis.
Thank you, mommette, very nice and relaxing.
I'm glad you like felt that.
Though returning to Kremlin mode is good too, yeah, that's more like me.
Best of luck on monetization.
Thank you for the tip, and yes, for that kind of thing, I'm most likely going to be doing free content on Twitter.
Thank you for the tip.
That was amazing.
Please, for the love of all, that is strong.
Keep an eye out for all of this posted.
I never did anything wrong in this stream.
I have done everything correct, but this is a sensory toy, and it's my favorite ASMR trigger right now.
Listen to it.
Isn't that amazing?
Thank you so much for that tip, real good catmuss.
But yeah, I didn't do anything wrong this stream.
But if you didn't know, AC Snowballs is live right now doing a DJ session.
So if you're needing this to be a bit more, if you're needing a bit more hype for your stream,
definitely check her out.
M.A.
Shabby
and Azura.
I believe we're all going live as well.
This is the shortest stream for me.
We will be redirecting into Shabby Cottonbomb.
Sounds like a piece of rubber stuck to the surface.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hey, yeah, I was a good girl this stream.
I did everything correct, yeah.
Sounds like one of those squeeze stress toys.
Yeah, that's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
I just don't want to risk it, and also you only want to say the name, right?
I don't even know what I said.
I forgot your hypercore.
Wait, you're going already?
No.
I'm going to do, Jen, I'm going to do gremlin ASMR.
I'm going to do ASMR like me.
Look, I even have this to put on your ears.
Are you ready?
Look, look, look, look, look.
I'm going to put this on your ears.
Ready?
Look.
You're almost home.
You get my gremlin ASMR.
Yeah.
This is so nice.
I'm rubbing them all against your ears.
I put winter earmuffs on your ears.
What?
Wow, then I did stream with absolutely no ears.
What do you mean by cats fighting at the start of the stream?
They're not going to leave a like, and then don't leave my sound.
Yeah, you're so fluffy.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
You're so fluffy.
First time moving into ASMR, I'm going to come back for more.
Glad I could take it.
It's nice to have a short stream to recover from your infinite stamina.
My voice is really broken, but because I'm whispering, you can't tell it's broken.
Some people like chugging ASMR.
I have lots of chugging water.
Okay.
Have I been a good girl for you?
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, I forgot my tea.
I've got a cold cup of tea over here.
But I was having a lot of fun doing that ASMR, and really...
Sorry, my throat is making throat noises.
Yeah, but this is just going to be an easier stream, because I don't want to break my voice.
This is the closest I've ever been to me.
Filly turns to me.
I'm usually so focused on trying to go under.
See?
But I think because I didn't plan any of what I was saying, because I was like natural, it made it easier to enjoy.
You know?
That's probably why.
Be a good girl and swallow what you...
Reflings were trying to leave this up.
Will you ever do a full hypno video?
Yeah, definitely.
I need to make sure I make it safe though.
I need to educate myself a bit more, because I need it all to be safe.
Which is why I'm not doing any permanent effects on this stream, because I may or may not have an interest in permanent effects,
but I already have an audio recorded that undoes any effects that I may do on you.
But I really like the permanent effects stuff.
I'm sorry, it's just what I'm interested in, and I may want to break you a little bit, but just a little bit.
It's not going to be bad or anything.
Like it's just going to be a wee bit of breaking, okay?
Just a wee bit.
Not a big bit.
So yeah, I need to make sure I do it 100% safe.
And it's filbert.
Break me, mommie.
To keep up the buns, I just have to say, you and your eyes were astonishing.
Thank you.
I love it.
70% break, take or leave it, and before we commit work, right?
Hey, yeah.
Effects like what?
Oh, so there's like different kinds of like hypno, and so you can purposely make like trainer ones where like I train you,
like I literally path off your subconscious to react to me, or to do something, or react in a certain way.
And I need to make sure it's super safe, and I need if I do an audio that basically states that like I don't have an effect on you anymore.
It tells your subconscious to throw everything that you learned out the window, and then it's all safe.
Welcome to Stronikato's YouTube, where safety number one priority.
Thoughts already doomed.
Stroni and her permanent effect will be like you will only donate your ink to me.
Basically, kind of.
It's the plan.
I want to do like sessions that last two hours long.
I can't wait.
I know my voice is going to be fried, but yeah.
Will there be lullabies for the replay?
My voice is broken, but I know you are my sunshine.
You are my sunshine.
My only sunshine.
You make me happy.
When skies are grey, you'll never know, dear, much I love you.
So please don't take my feet laying away.
Lullabies!
I don't know many other lullabies.
Would be cool if you had a button that made the camera zoom in on your eyes.
Oh, well, next stream I'll have a tracker, so it follows my head around.
So you can't escape my eyes, but I wanted to go very easy.
Very easy on the first one.
Please don't take my sunshine away.
Ta-da!
There is that cradle one.
The cradle you will fall.
Rock, bye, baby, on the tree top.
When the wind blows, the cradle will rock.
I don't know the rest.
What were your inspirations for being a no-themed career?
I've always, always loved it.
I've always loved it, but I have always known how deep the rabbit hole goes.
And I've touched on surface level, but I was like, I want to go rabbit hole.
Sorry, the wire is spilling on the desk.
I want to go all in, baby, all in.
So, well, the table at the top will be fixed.
I can fix it now if you tell me how to spell the word.
What's the word?
Be-er-meh.
Was it ah?
Be-er-meh-ne-ed.
Okay, there you go.
Just like that, see, I can do it.
Okay, I can even add to bring Kremlin.
Kremlin.
Wow, look at that.
Super professional.
Sorry.
We're going down the heaven of the world.
Yeah, there's like so much to it that I just knew I couldn't do it until it was time.
And now it's time.
Well, tippy-tippy.
I'm Kremlin-ized, yeah.
Don't be expecting anything serious from me.
Oh, did you like my- I've loathe- obnoxiously loathe my keyboardist.
Oh, yeah.
It's so good.
So, I, for triggers, I like double finger-clicking.
I like finger-clicking.
For words or phrases, I want to do what you kindly-
I want to do me-haps, because I say me-haps all the time.
Me-haps-ree-fling.
You want to go deeper.
Would you kindly-ree-fling go deeper with me?
Like, oh, those are such good trigger words.
But, yeah.
Is Johnny's susceptible to hypnosis?
Yes!
My biggest enemy are mirrors.
Unfortunately, I can fall to my own hypnosis, but it only lasts 24 hours.
It's fain, it's fain.
Would you kindly- would be hilarious?
Yes, we're literally doing it off of BioShock.
Look, look, we're gamers out here, okay?
We're gamers.
We're here for the memes as well, but it doesn't mean we can't incorporate our favorite games into our other activities.
Johnny drilling on the floor in front of a mirror.
Stop!
I want to order so much artwork about all these, like, different plots.
I'm like, oh no, the reeflings have found me.
I'm just gonna beat you into a mirror.
We didn't- oh no.
But we are doing hypnosis in general, but I've already done the segment because I need to be gremlin gamer mode right now.
Because it's me, I can't help it.
I'm just a freaking meme lord, it's hard to be serious, okay?
Yeah, enjoy the memes while enjoying our- you didn't finish that segment.
Why are you not finishing?
We're out here gaming.
We're only big gamers here, you tons of games.
Remember that a man-
a man bleeds a slave obeys and reeflings feel brave.
For the orders coming from the queue, he put on a suit for your serious stream.
Oh, a man chooses- oops, sorry.
A man chooses a reefling obeys.
Oh wait, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, wait, pause, pause, pause the tunes.
Okay, hold on, pause the tunes, pause the tunes.
Oh hi, I see in berries, hold on, we're caught in bio shock.
A man chooses a reefling obeys.
Oh wait, why is my freaking calibration? I was looking at the pollin'.
Hi, A.C. in snowberries, I promise I'm not trying to hypnotize you, we're in gremlin hours, okay?
Hi, A.C. girl, I was your rave, I hope your voice is okay.
I was watching you in the bath again.
I take a bath every morning to try and steam my throat before stream.
In A.C.'s live, so I was watching her and she dressed up as a princess the way Mercy drew her.
If you guys didn't see Mercy drew her, turn it off, it was amazing.
Maybe at the end of stream, I will do, I will do maybe serious mode, okay?
I'm actually gonna make sure I'm breathing into Sheebie.
Sorry, I'm reflecting to the screen right now.
But yeah, let's just, hold on, customization redirect.
We partied now, all the snowberries are tired, little babies.
Sheebie's playing call of the lamb.
Oh my god, I think me and Sheebie might be doing multiplayer call of the lamb.
Is it Sheebie first and then Azura and then Mercy?
Who's coming online first, Azura or Mercy?
Eh, Azura or Sheebie?
She had a big Mercy.
Ujisan party?
Ah, it's tall, that's terrible.
Did the Ujisans have a good time or are you all ready for a nap after that?
Hold on, I'll just check who comes online first.
Is Azura or Azura?
Wait, where's, I just don't know.
I'm sure the girl's on my screen.
But yeah, it's first Azura live and have a long Azura's live all the way in 5, 10.
Okay, no, it's definitely Sheebie that comes up next.
Sorry, it was amazing.
Oh, Ujisans, time to put you to sleep.
Come here, old man.
You're done fainting.
You party so hard with Azura.
And she showed you how much energy she has, yeah.
Oh, and you've used up all your energy, Ujisan.
They may be asleep, but I can't let you sleep.
I'm ready to jump up on you.
Yeah, I made a little induction at the end of the stream,
but right now we're crammin' mode, okay?
I can't be serious.
I laughed, I cried, I ooooh, I'm supposed to even pronounce that.
Even in our ASMR stream, she speaks fast.
Oh yeah, you think that's speakin' fast?
Can you be serious, not for long?
Crammin' mode activated, yeah.
Shhh, we're real ASMRs out here.
I'm speakin' an enchanted main craft table.
It's pronounced U-O-U-O.
Surely you can be serious, but what was that?
It's called Ace Globes.
Because A.C. finished their stream, I'm using Ace Globes.
I fell farther in love with my cute and funny Ujisan puffing.
Oh shit, and this is why we don't have chat on screen during ASMR's streams.
What is that? It's the unknown.
A.C. should introduce you to Igar, his Igar.
Ace Globes are so nice, yeah.
Mercy had some Ace Globes in her ASMR, and Emmy got Scamaste on Ace Globes.
I don't know if she said the story yet, so I'll let her tell the story.
I feel better already.
You and Igar will get along well.
I feel better already, yay.
There's no permanent influence on this stream, what does that mean?
So some hypnosis ASMRists like to mark you and leave you with a present,
and I'm not doing that because we are slowly working our way.
You have to take things slow and take your time,
and I'm gonna take my time with you briefly,
and get you all tired.
Oh, it's a reference to the polar bear game.
Would you ever use water next to a $2,000 microphone?
I don't know, this is the best water you're gonna get.
Permanent hypnosis is just a gift that keeps on giving.
Slow indoctrination.
Would you kindly rethink?
Let me do what I want to you.
Shh, it's time to come down from the party snow berries.
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
You're under the sea, don't need hypnosis for that.
Always.
Today was already a chill day for me, so this stream was really fun, I'm glad.
I'll try to do ASMR streams every week.
Yeah, my back hurts, okay, true OG suns for it.
But yes, I will do ASMR every week.
Some more intense than the others, some plots as well,
like fill probably plots, make them live.
And I do, like, when I get you guys to talk and give me suggestions,
I do apologize if you type for me to say something.
I had to make sure it fitted with the theme,
which is why I brought you up so I can start being a gremlin again,
because I didn't want you to be down and be gremlin mode.
Big Willy Wallace is moribbly wet.
My back's gone after that DJ stream.
That's so good.
I break from my own mind every week, yeah.
Oh yeah, some good plots, oh yeah.
Some real deep thought-provoking plots.
Okay, let me see if there's freaking tracking.
I think, because I'm not sure.
Okay.
Okay, I think this better.
My mouse tracking just kind of stops working after all.
I think it gets confused with the ASMR mic.
You like the background things.
I made it myself.
I did it.
I'm not like you did an Adobe After Effects.
Past streamer and vealer.
All my girls were past streamer and vealer.
They're all the best.
Yeah, no.
You do you, Strani, we still love you.
Yeah.
That background is amazing, yes.
I can also go faster or slower,
but I'll do that another time.
But just so that I can really make it intense, okay?
Like, I, this, this sound you hear,
this, I can also make it faster and more intense.
So please don't think I haven't thought this through.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's over for you.
Don't resist.
There's no point in resisting.
Okay, love, rethink.
You are main.
Just give me some time.
Just let me kick.
Me kick.
There.
And then what?
Oh no, all my money's going into your pocket.
That's terrible, rethink.
Yeah.
That sound doesn't have any side effects.
No, none of them have secret.
I have no secret agenda.
Thank you, window for cracking during the ASMR stream.
That window cracked like three times during my segments.
I was like, really, you're getting rude.
I wasn't sure if I liked the background noise,
but I really like it.
Oh, if you don't like that noise,
don't worry, I'll train you to like it.
Just stop resisting.
Your efforts are futile.
You will not win against me.
I have unending stamina.
Are my streams not proof enough?
Wah, thank you for the tip.
Irwin Blair, thank you for the tip.
Yes, let's give all money to feel it.
Thank you for the tip, Irwin.
Support my babies.
Support my babies so they can move out.
And I can buy them a better internet connection.
Thank you so much for the tip, though.
I appreciate it greatly.
I need some hydration.
You can hear some ASMR gulps.
All gone.
None left.
Thank you.
Wow.
Strani does the cuttlefish throw perfect.
Only at one speed.
Yes, only one speed.
I didn't want people to think I'm doing a rave.
I'll fate mommy's unending stamina with my own.
Let's see her come set one top.
Me.
Oh, the cuttlefish is going to give.
I can't read that out.
Oh, my money's going to skew.
For those of you who did train in a little late,
my YouTube channel has been spent for monetization.
I'm actually getting a manicure and a pedicure today
in preparation for my monetization stream.
So there's your hint.
Hopefully it comes through quickly.
And I'm very excited.
Zeroed in audible.
Yeah, I did it into my...
I'm wearing a hoodie.
But yeah, I'm getting my first ever manicure and pedicure.
I have no idea what...
I think they like massage your legs as well.
So I'm going to like get nice and smooth and like shave my legs.
Just to make sure they don't have to touch my like stubbly legs.
But yeah, I will be interesting.
Maybe I should like live tweet my experience and being like,
Oh, the person's doing this now.
They're doing this to my foot.
Because I've never had like a pedicure is when it's your feet.
Because pediatry is feet care.
And then manicure, man-manjitables are your hands.
And while the rest of the fee allergen begin monetization too,
yes, they are being submitted today.
I believe we are waiting for the YouTube stats to update
because they're taking their sweet time.
It took a week for the statistics to update.
And then everyone is doing their monetization celebration streams.
And ooh, everyone's eating good.
That's all I'm going to say.
It may as well be...
Oh no, it may as well be Thanksgiving.
What the fuck?
My tech...
What?
What the fuck?
My phone?
My tech talk?
I was so scared.
Oh my God.
My phone...
My tech talk just opened up on its own.
Bruh, China's listening in.
What the fuck?
I...what the fuck?
My phone just opened up on its own
to play a freaking advertisement to me.
What was that?
I thought someone was outside in the garden.
I was like, oh my God, there's someone outside my house.
I need to end stream right now.
That was scary.
Oh my God.
I was so scared there.
I was like, what?
China, I'll prove to you, sir.
My Chinese grade just went up by 100K.
That was horrifying.
I thought that was...
I was like, what?
I should be the only thing making noise
because what was that?
What?
My heart rate is exhilarated.
Literally my social credit just went up.
What on earth?
I think that was an ad because I opened tech talk
and then it loaded a video or something.
We can hire her.
She said, I'm not doing hypnosis.
I'm gremlin mode.
Read the top.
That's what you get for having TikTok.
That's what I get for brain run.
That was scary.
Jeez.
Okay, what was I saying before that?
Oh, monetization.
Wait, is monetization a trigger word
for the TikTok spice?
They want the money too.
What is it?
Do you want heart beat ASMR?
I don't think I have a ceiling on it.
A member ceiling.
The numbers may send, honestly.
Because I was talking about monetization in the hand.
TikTok loves monetization.
I said, yeah, give me some of that.
Jeez.
Okay.
Let's drag you back into ASMR.
That freaked me out.
That was scary because I was like, hello?
Hello, who's there?
Refill yourself.
Refill, yes I do.
Okay.
Just save money.
Shhh.
I accidentally woke up.
What happened?
My freaking phone started playing ads.
Even though I didn't touch my phone at all.
I don't like, I'm not bringing.
I don't like that.
That was scary.
We're in your walls.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let's see if we can do heart beat ASMR.
I need to put you over my hoodie, okay?
But maybe a little loud.
But this is my heart.
I'll do this side because it's easier.
You have one.
Thank you.
Can you hear it?
Can you hear my heart at all?
Yeah.
That's my heart beat.
Is it fast or slow?
It might be fast because I'm talking.
That's why at the doctor's office,
they tell you not to talk
when you take the pressure cuff on your arm.
Do you want to see how fast my heart can go?
We're going to mess around, okay?
I'm going to turn the volume down.
Okay.
And that's just my heart.
I'm hearing mummies.
You hear my stomach sound?
Stop.
That's how fast my heart can really go.
Can I ruin a surprise for you guys?
Because it's my content,
I'm allowed to ruin the surprise, okay?
The stomach was louder than the heart now.
I'm going to do an ASMR video,
like a role play,
where you are pregnant
and you're in my tummy
and I'm talking to you about how proud I am
and how excited I am
for everything you're going to achieve in your life.
And I can't wait for you to experience the world
and it's going to have my actual heart beat
and stomach sounds in it.
And I'm going to tell you
all that you deserve,
all the good things in life that happen.
And I'm going to be your cheerleader.
And yeah, I need to get the artwork commissioned though,
because I need to draw me pregnant with you in my tummy.
And I'll be wearing like a mummy outfit and everything.
So yeah, and I'm going to tell you
how excited I am for you to get to know you
and I get to see what your personality is like
and you're going to be perfect in every way.
Because there's no way that my little refling can do any wrong.
That's strangely, yeah,
and you're going to hear my tummy sounds and my heart beat
and my voice is going to be muffled.
It's going to be like this, okay.
This is what my voice is going to sound like.
And I'm so proud of you.
Now my voice is so broken.
I'm sorry I broke my voice,
so this doesn't sound very pleasant.
But I'm so proud of you
and I can't wait to meet you
and I can't wait to watch you grow up
and do all the things you love
and see what hobbies you fall in love with.
And you're going to be so smart like your mummy.
Yeah.
Your broken voice sounds like sadness.
Oh no, I know it's sad.
I'm even sad that I didn't have my cup of tea,
but I had a lot of fun getting you very deep into the moment.
Who's the daddy?
Are you, again, refling?
Don't you not know the failure or the lore?
The reason why I have five dollars
is all because of the reflings.
See, in order to make sure that no one refling
can claim that they're the daddy,
all of us got together,
turned the lights out and just went for it.
Okay, we just went for it.
That's how we have five dollars.
Okay.
We should do that again sometime.
Oh yeah.
You want to find out what book it is?
We're both hired out.
We've actually been confirmed
that we are showing up to a convention
but it's in 2025.
But I think it's in California.
Yeah.
I'm all the reflings on the daddy.
No, I won't take my meds.
But yeah, very excited.
I don't know, it would be nice if we could all meet
up at a convention,
but I don't know how the girls feel about her.
And I have absolutely horrific traveling anxiety.
So I'm going to be so high.
I'm going to be high on medications.
I'm paying for that bag storage box.
Honestly, I'm the father.
Oh, I'm the father, does a back flip.
Can the VIP treatment?
Oh yeah.
I wish I could go to the con.
I don't know if I can go to the con.
So please do not book any conventions.
For this whole purpose, in case I show up,
that's not how it works.
Mummies do weaknesses, traveling, mirrors.
I mean, I'll fill it in another stream.
Yeah, it's a very unfunny story.
It's a friend in the toilet.
My backyard would love to go next.
That would be really cute, yeah.
Understood booking all conventions on the slim chance that you show up.
Oh my gosh, but then,
stick an entire brief worth of people in a tumble dryer
and you basically get all the feel.
If we basically boomed you with five dollars,
shall we do it again with another five?
No.
With another six.
Come on, mommy needs to cook.
Like 41 hours away from California.
I think it's in California.
I don't actually know where it is.
Six, yeah.
Every gen and veiler.
In theory, has six girls.
And there should be one design
of each that you gravitate towards.
That's right.
I may not be the smartest,
but I know what to do sometimes.
But I like being dumb.
I like reeflings doing all the thinking for me.
What if you gravitate towards all the designs?
I don't know.
I feel like one has to speak to you.
So you are the oven.
I'm just an oven.
I just need you to fill it.
Let's be dumb together.
You're great except for the naming part, exactly.
What do you mean, strawnee 365?
I wonder if I called myself strawnee 365
because my secret goal was to stream
every single day for a year.
But, yeah, we're already going to blow that out of the water
unless I'm gravely ill.
Smooth out the brain wrinkles.
This is something I can get by it.
What if I'm gravitated towards the accent instead?
They know so go in me.
I, you like this accent.
That's what tickles your pickle.
Or then you make me,
I'll tickle that pickle any day I will.
What do you mean?
You'll always be my arsy.
Arsy, thank you.
See, I'm here because Fiche,
who doesn't like Fiche,
also impressive Xbox Game Collection.
What's that?
Yeah, he's been Xbox good.
Oh, so cool.
I used to be one of those kids in the YouTube comments
that were like,
Xbox is so much cooler than PlayStation.
Yeah, and PlayStation sucks, yeah.
Yeah.
That accent is good.
It's above.
That accent's funny.
It can be sexy when I put it on.
I feel like if I want to do like a voice that commands you,
I need to go deeper.
I'm a console warfare, and yeah.
See, I was bursted,
and I had to be a stud from a car boot sale for a five-hour playstation.
Yeah, PlayStation drills.
Strangely, I was on the right team for a day one.
No beating that.
Count me or she get location.
The Scottish accent is sexy.
I didn't know how.
Like my actual accent when I'm monthly.
I'm like, oh, who's it going, lads?
Yep, this is so as I'm laced.
We better have some backpapes at the convention.
No, that's awful.
I double in 360, but I was a Nintendo kid.
Nintendo was so expensive.
My dad got me a Nintendo DS,
but he was always happier to let me buy like secondhand
Xbox 360 games over Nintendo's secondhand,
because it was so expensive.
We used to have this game shop in the UK called GameStop or Game.
I think they both went past, I can't remember.
And basically,
wait, what?
They went past, but they used to sell secondhand games,
and that's how I got all my games.
They used to do what was called trade-ins,
and I would have to trade in my games to get new ones.
I think Game Stations Buster, yeah.
Wasn't it called EP Games?
No, not in the UK, not that I know of.
You aren't wrong though about Nintendo being far too expensive.
Yes, and they just shut down the eNintendo store.
I think GameStop is still a thing.
Did you ever go to CEX?
I don't think so.
I think most game stores did a version of a trade-in model.
Yeah, that's how I got my games.
It's been Game Stations.
Oh, maybe it's Game Stations that at GameStop.
Maybe Game Station.
Just remember, I was a weebap,
I just looked at the covers of the games and went,
Dad, I want that one.
EP is...
Wait, what?
EP Games was in the UK?
Oh, yeah, no, I...
Yeah.
If it went past in 2002, yeah, no.
I never experienced EP Games.
I was Xbox for a long time then Switch
because the Japanese make some fire games.
Yeah.
Game is still a thing in the UK.
GameStop is still a thing in the US.
I'll go.
EP Games.
We're just EP sleepy gamers.
I miss choosing games by the cover now I Google them.
Things endlessly.
Yeah.
If you're ever one in a new game to completely time sync
and you play PC for mods,
I recommend the painting of Isaac
and I'm not recommending it
just so you guys can all princess carry me through the game.
It's a very big game.
Big game, big game.
Yeah.
In the UK, this game now, GameStation,
go buy a buy-up.
Oh, go, go, go.
EP Games was absorbed by GameStop.
Oh my god, we're getting the lore.
We're getting the capitalism lore.
Yeah, painting of Isaac.
Yeah.
The painting of Isaac.
The painting of Isaac doesn't work anymore in your PC, huh?
Yeah.
I had an Xbox, just an Xbox.
Oh, the Xbox original.
I wanted to get my 360,
but I think it's messed up.
It's the largest console I own by a country male.
Here's a war handstone based story.
I'm sure I've just misread that,
but you actually made cameo.
Yeah, it's like fantasy game.
It's really nice.
If you're talking about Xbox exclusives,
if you're talking about overall,
yeah, Assassin's Creed Brotherhood,
yeah, sorry, you've just miss,
you've just misspelled Assassin's Creed as fine as it.
You spell it as, as in, Creed.
Yeah.
No, it's fine.
You've just misspelled.
Don't worry about it.
I can read through what you're missing.
Any fellow guitar hero enjoyers?
I wish Army of Two was multiplayer,
but no, I don't think.
I would love to do Army of Two.
Oh, did you ever have a Game Boy?
I did, and I had like three Game Boy games.
My dad, so if my dad bought the console,
he would let me play it basically,
and he bought a Game Boy,
and he didn't like it, so he gave it to me.
And I played Pokemon Ribby.
I played Legend of Zelda Minish Cap.
And one more game that I,
I'm sure there's one more game I probably played.
I forgot.
The Minish Cap is my only Zelda game.
Oh, my voice is breaking.
Legend of Zelda Minish Cap.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, no.
Wait, no, sorry.
Tapping ASMR.
Little, little tappies.
It doesn't actually sound that nice.
I don't know what 33 Immortals is.
I haven't heard about it, have we?
What's your favorite Pokemon?
And why is it Shandler?
I actually didn't mean lightweight.
Lightweight is so cute.
But see, Pokemon have this thing
where they make a really cute, adorable, creepy Pokemon,
and then its evolution is Auckland.
I didn't want ugly, ugly evolutions.
Lightweight is adorable.
It's an MMO.
Oh, no, we're knee-deep in RuneScape right now.
I took the console with me everywhere.
It'd be the crap out of the paints worn out,
but it still works.
All old-school games, I don't see.
Literally think of, what is it?
Joystick Drift?
No, that's not a gender name.
Is it Joy-Con Drift?
Oh, that's a Joy-Con Drift on Nintendo Switch.
But Game Boy Advance is that we're made.
How many years back still work?
I'm catching up on old-school RuneScape vision now.
Did y'all know there was a Pokemon card game on Game Boy?
No.
It's in the up-gaming.
Sorry, my voice is cracking.
Hello, I've got 25 minutes,
and then I'm going for an official vocal rest
and we are reading into Shibi playing.
If you didn't know, Cult of the Lamb is a 10 out of 10 game.
I rate it very highly.
I had a Game Boy card game.
It was so fun.
Courtney was so hot as Courtney.
The Game Boy card game was actually really good.
Sorry, can't go back to sleep.
May as well cook something.
Oh, very good.
And Jack and Kenabiana.
Ah!
Hey, yo.
Cult of the Lamb isn't your first update.
Cult of the Lamb's multiplayer,
so I'm going to force Shibi to play it with me.
I still have my Pokemon card game on Game Boy.
Yeah.
Gonna go at work, see you next dream.
Yeah, I'm ending.
We're gonna redirect into Shibi in 20 minutes, okay?
You should play with us as cultists
then starting kiki-kiki.
I don't know how the multiplayer works,
but we'll see.
Cult of the Lamb is Twitch integration.
I don't know if YouTube wants to do that kind of in-game integration or not.
Damn, it feels like the stream just started.
I mean, in terms of insurance, yeah.
Have you ever played War Thunder?
Yeah, I saw it.
It's local co-op.
I could have sworn.
Horn, as all they said, had multiplayer.
Am I going crazy?
What are you doing after stream?
I'm gonna make a cup of tea to soothe my throat.
And then I'm going to message clippers
or check any clips that the girls might have had.
And then I'm gonna get a manicure and a pedicure.
I can't believe I'm saying that,
but yes, I'm going to get a manicure and a pedicure.
And then I'm going to edit some ASMRs in preparation of getting monetised
so I can upload those 1K special videos
and I will probably write the script for the pregnant with you ASMR that I want to make
and I'll most likely contact an artist as well about it.
But yeah.
Quite a few things I need to catch up on.
Especially with the Endurance Streams.
I'll probably be listening to Shibi in the background as she plays.
So whoever said War Thunder, you only play that game if you hate yourself.
But yes, I have a big day, big day.
I don't know if I should show a picture of my feet and hands afterwards
because some people don't like streamers that do like hand cam or whatever.
I'm very sorry if, you know, get vellard, get vellard, get vellard, but yeah.
Literally tomorrow you get to see my hands.
Wow.
Whilst I eat the American candy.
I get to try A&W visages.
It's like a cream and soda, I said, but I don't normally drink cream and soda.
And what other?
I think there is Twizzlers.
There is like Spacey Hall, Cheetos or something.
Or Takis.
I get to try Takis.
There's 20 grippers.
Wait, do you want me to put the feet in the stream as well?
I mean, I can do it.
I can put my feet in the stream if you want.
Okay.
You wish is my command.
Look, you guys don't understand.
Like, you may be used to streamers out here that don't do what you want.
You do not understand.
I will do what you want.
Send me what you want.
Let me know.
Look, as much as I am in command of you, you are in command of me.
I will think of a humorous way to incorporate my feet into more stream, okay?
Call us kid names.
My little baby replay.
We need the scrawny thighs.
Can I put thighs?
I don't know.
I've not decided on my outfit.
I think I'm just wearing fishnets.
I'm sorry.
I can't believe I actually have to put clothes on for a vacant stream.
You guys are terrible.
Please don't put on my smell.
Right, I'm just going to check Marshmallow.
Just because we're actually getting really close to the end.
Oh, that's a lot of Marshmallows.
Oh my.
That was a lot more than yesterday.
Yeah.
What's mommy going to do?
Mommy's going to do whatever she wants.
Mommy's going to do whatever she wants to.
Oh, sorry.
I love your hypnosis.
I get happy every time I go under someone else's influence.
I'm so glad that it's so well during that section.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, sorry, I'm reading Marshmallows,
but pretty much none of them can be said on stream.
Yippee!
This is the part where I'm supposed to be like a business person.
I'm supposed to be like,
oh, but what does my ghost do it?
Are you a bit of an emmy?
I mean, I could try and do hypnosis again,
but it's probably not going to be that good.
I need to be in the zone to corrupt you,
but because I've been allowed to me, I feel like myself.
And I'm just some goofy dork, like, honestly.
Business strongy, yapper strongy, professional strongy.
I wear so many hats.
Why is animus showing us a strange coat of false thoughts?
Not enough time.
Your error, goofy dork.
Yay, communist hole.
I've already prayed in obedience.
Jokes on you, how many of them?
Uh...
Hey strongy, after a year of waiting,
you've really surprised me.
Well, I'm just...
I have been afraid to die for a while
and decided I'd support your project regardless of the quality,
but the girls are great and the content is stellar.
I'm glad.
I usually just work at lurk and watch streams,
but I felt like I had to tell you,
I love mommy and I love when she's...
and I love what she's done with the place.
I love you too, little refling.
I'm so glad you love the girls as well.
I was really worried that,
like, you guys would think,
like, go support them, you know?
Cause I'm like that.
She said she wasn't in a hidden program
and I hope you're having as much as a good time as the reflings are
and in any case, thank you.
Oh, I'm having a good time.
The only reason I ain't doing insurance...
That's my voice and this is how I'm talking.
I'm a little broken,
but I can bypass that by whispering at the moment.
That's the reason why I'm not doing an insurance stream today or tomorrow.
But don't worry, you can fix me.
I just need some of your ink, okay?
So send me your ink and marshmallow right now.
Wait, we got a tip. I need to read it.
Let me read it.
Airwind player, thank you for the tip.
That's the way today. Thank you so much for the hypnosis.
Look forward to what's to come.
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
Really amazed at how good this is going.
Much love, thank you.
Don't strain your voice by whispering too much.
It's really weird because I broke...
So my voice has broken and whispering breaks your voice further,
but I can bypass my voice right now by whispering.
It's crazy. I don't know how it works.
We whisper.
Yes.
Very inkable.
The urge to use my tongue right now is very high,
but I shan't.
I won't refrain from such sins.
I won't refrain, okay?
Getting it, getting it, getting it. Incredible.
But yeah, I'll go on vocal rest for today
because I don't have to record anything
and I need to send collab partner scripts.
Wow!
Sly Saber, thank you for the tip.
It says, thanks for the ASMR. Here's your inking.
My voice is so broken.
Dainy, spainy, thank you for the tip.
I just got some iron bread delivered shop.
So I'll try scotch soda for the first time tomorrow on stream
when you try porn stuff.
Yay, let's go.
I have iron bread too.
Actually, I'll drink iron bread with you.
Oh, you made me ink.
Like, it's supposed to be good for the throat, okay?
I'm so professional, okay?
But yeah, I will definitely take a really good look
at Marshmallows shortly.
A lot of them cannot be said.
Mayhaps in membership streams.
You never know.
Nine out of ten doctors recommend,
oh yeah, our refling's doctors.
Good for the throat, sure.
I mean, want to find her?
This is terrible.
Don't you want to help me?
Help me feel better?
Come on.
If you can do something to help me,
I'll be good, okay?
But you need to be good in return.
Be good for me.
Give me what I need.
That's terrible.
Okay, no going under.
No going under, stop.
It's just me.
I'm still memeing, okay?
I'm still memeing.
Not a doctor, but three years into a doctorate.
If mummy asks refling's answer,
what, another tip?
Irwin Blair, thank you for the tip.
Yeah, it helps Johnny.
I don't know why sometimes the message displays
and then it doesn't display.
It's been so silly.
Can you make your back wrinkle a bit faster?
Right now, I don't think so.
But I do have alternative
dingy mobobbers.
Oh wait, here we go. Are you ready?
Wait.
Yeah.
I can do like this.
It's going so fast.
Do we need to slow down or do we need to speed up?
That's terrible.
Isn't it?
Just terrible.
But that's as fast as I can make it.
Okay?
So hopefully that's faster now.
Speed up or slow down?
Yeah.
Faster, faster, faster, faster, faster.
Okay.
That should be the correct settings.
I think.
Trucks on you are always under.
Yeah, I get to set the pace.
Just don't make it too fast.
Don't want anyone out here.
Let's see.
Ta-da!
Tip.
Nero, thank you for the tip.
He says all my ink belongs to you, Johnny.
You just need to ask,
have I broken you already?
Yeah?
Am I allowed to break you?
Have I still got the effect on my voice
or is it normal again?
Wait, what?
What?
My pupils are broken.
It's normal.
Okay, you broke us a long time ago.
Can't break what's already broken.
Dang.
I see a few of you are already broken in for me.
You broke me at a low.
Your hair looks like the famous spiral candy.
I forgot its name.
I don't know what it is.
My seashells or my hair.
I'm going to be honest,
I wouldn't take much.
It's over.
That's cheating, Johnny.
Look, I will get my way.
I said an ending stamina.
I meant it.
He broke me at a low.
It's true.
Your voice is so entrancing.
Yeah.
When it's not broken, hopefully I will do better soon.
And I can have much more ASMR.
I am folding like a towel.
No, it's not. It's brain milled.
An ending stamina gives me every time.
Yeah, it does.
It should.
Should I do vocal requests for the rest of the stream?
And you guys type what you want me to say.
It's the sofa format.
I did that under a serious ASMR.
There's only so much banner I can draw.
I'm just scuttlebreed, okay?
I'm just a bit scuttlebreed.
I'm already folded on top of the linen closet ready for use.
You're asking for all you want me 10 to 0.
We've only got 8 minutes left.
8 minutes.
I don't even know if I'm allowed to do your kissing.
My tummy's making a noise.
Can you hypnotize us to make your dogs for a shabby stream?
I would love to do that.
Can we do that?
Can we please do that?
Please, let me hypnotize you to be a dog for a shabby stream.
Let me set up for this.
I'm so serious.
I need to set up for this.
Hold on, let me drink some water as well.
I'm so serious.
I am so serious.
Let me just de-grammify myself because we're in serious mode.
Hold on, one last calibration.
Because this iPhone is killing me.
Let's get to work.
Oh no, that's not it.
There, there.
I'm not the only one that can look after you this way.
In fact, I have five more that I refer to as my daughters.
There is one who will join you soon.
She will look after you.
But there's a cat with a leafling.
You need to be well behaved, okay?
Almost like a dog.
You know how to be a good dog, don't you?
You need to be malleable, follow commands.
Be told what to do, what to say, what to think.
You are nothing but a pup for her amusement.
And in her, you will amuse me.
So be good.
Don't worry, it'll wear off soon.
After her stream.
But for now, good pup speak.
And they go park, don't they?
Yeah.
And then, they wait on the command of their owner.
You are owned, do you understand?
You do not have free will.
You're a mutt.
Ready to do the bidding of your owner.
So let her have fun, okay?
And in turn, I will have fun, and you will have fun.
So don't think, no until you're told otherwise.
Because in three minutes, I'm going to hand the imaginary leash over to your new owner.
Don't worry, it's temporary.
But you'd like that, wouldn't you?
Get to play with a new owner for a while.
Good pup, you deserve some head pads, don't you?
Oh, you're a good boy.
Such a good boy.
And it feels so rewarding to hear praise, doesn't it?
In two minutes, you get your new owner, just temporary, for a little while.
And she'll give you all the attention you need, all the love.
And I'll reward you extra when you come back to me, okay?
So you'll be good, won't you, little pup?
I've taught you well, you know how to behave.
So be good, in one minute, your new owner will take your leash and build you along with her.
Okay?
Good little pup, such a good, good boy.
Oh, I hear her, she's coming.
I hope you're ready.
Zero.
Good dog.